To crash on a crossroad,
You are always faced with the underlying traffic problem.
In the green light, the first car gives gas, then the other,
then the other, then the other and then you,
just to get to red.
If the cars would give gas at the same time
you could go out.
Coordination - not the cars - is the problem
because we are monkey guitars with immediate reaction in time
and brief attention.
Even if we take everyone to break the gas in 3-2-1-Now
it would be challenging.
This lack of coordination limits how many cars can cross a crossroads
and when no one supports one another,
the city's street network is blocked, and it requires a perennietà to be solved.
In general, the more crossings are equated with more non-coordination, which equates to more traffic.
This is the reason for the major highways: No crossroads.
Divide and join, Yes. Crossroads, No.
No stops, no coordination problems, no traffic.
Well this is the theory anyway.
Cruises outside a car park would turn the problem back.
And again, because the human reaction limits how many cars can go out
when the color of the traffic light is changed
But even without intersections, there would still be traffic on the highway.
Traffic can simply be displayed.
Let's take a highway with happy cars.
until a chicken crosses the road.
The driver who looks at it curbs a little,
the driver behind him does not notice it immediately and stops a bit more than he needs.
the driver behind him does the same thing until someone stops completely.
and, see, the cars that are approaching the highway should also stop.
Although the chicken has long since disappeared, it has left a shadow of the crossroads on the highway.
This is what happens when you are stuck in full-time traffic thinking,
"There must be a cluster of dead before" and suddenly, the traffic ends
without any downside in the way, to make it easier for you to be a good man.
You simply pass through the shadow of the intersection,
the cause of which has disappeared over time.
And when this shadow crossroad moves.
It's really a traffic snake that crawls in the street
eating the cars coming to an end.
In a circular road, a single car slows down
will launch a "Ouroboros" traffic that would last a lifetime,
even when there is no problem with the road.
If drivers could co-ordinate to give gas and to divide them simultaneously,
could drive the car easily.
But they can not, so traffic gets stuck there.
On the highway, the traffic snake grows if cars are eaten faster than pulled out,
and they shrink if it is pulled out faster than they are eating,
disappearing when the last car gives gas before the other car stops.
Now, in many lanes, there is no need for chicken to block.
A driver crossing limbs quickly with cars very close behind, is enough
the traffic is born, a snake who lives for hours and leaves.
It is this fast pass that makes drivers behind to restrain and continue a zinzhir reaction.
But we can * make the traffic snake a little bit by changing the way we drive.
Your goal as a driver is to stay at the same distance from the car ahead
just like the car is back all the time.
Tracking is a problem. Not because it causes more accidents but
because as a trainer you can continue a traffic snake if the driver pauses.
Always in the middle!
This gives you more time to prevent over-braking
also gives the driver back time.
And when it comes to traffic,
this rule would make all cars take the snake with speed.
This is the simplest solution, changing people behavior,
maybe by distributing this video to show how and why traffic is happening,
why the pursuits are a problem, and how we can work together to make the best ways.
end
except, yes ..
to express the desire that people are better than they are, is a terrible solution
Forever.
Instead, what works is a structured solution,
which is fixed what cars without a driver do,
cars without a driver can simply be programmed
to stay in the middle and to give gas systematically.
They will just do it
The more cars without a driver at a crossroads, the crossroads become more efficient.
An uninterrupted lane with cars without a driver increases the lap time.
hmm, not really!
Even if we exclude people from the street
we can completely escape from the crossroads.
However, a traffic light is simply a driver for a road to communicate with other drivers
on the other, weak and rude.
Red means "Do not run away now, we're coming through the crossroads"
Green means "You can continue"
But drivers without a driver can talk to each other at the speed of light,
with those coordinates, no need for traffic lights.
As with the highway, the best crossroads are without crossing.
People will never ride correctly.
At intersections, the underlying problem is traffic
that you see unfurled, like everything, are people.
So the simplest solution to traffic is:
Do not have monkeys driving the car.
This video was brought to you by Audible.com